la l'ida nous approchons de noël
et puis demain c'est mercredi alors on
va penser un petit peu aux enfants
pendant quelques instants le temps d'un
reportage
vous connaissez la nouvelle chanson de
pierre perret la mère noël c8000 il a
appris qu'il y avait maintenant une mère
noël
alors nous sommes partis à la recherche
de cette mère noël et françois chaignaud
la trouver regardez
[Musique]
oh
et
mademoiselle un père noël comme celui-là
ça vous dit quelque chose c'est pas un
terminal comme les autres comment utile
bah c'est pas un homme c'est une femme
oui et si c'est pas moi je les reconnais
à sa voix son accent
tu a reconnu le père noël oui pièce
dalida à quoi la thur connu à l'action
je sais bien que tu l'as d'or et qu'elle
a déjà les yeux la vina mais tu es trop
jeune encore à la marina pour jouer les
amoureux
d'accord ce qu'a vécu comme jouer une
matra et bien j'arrive tout de suite a
tout de suite
d'abord c'est quelque chose de très beau
c'est la fête des enfants bien sûr et
ensuite pour moi ça représente un peu la
chanson et ma carrière parce que la
première fois que j'ai fait un avion du
caire repartir pour paris
eh bien c'était noël c'est le 25
décembre 1954
[Musique]